we were talking about you brought you
that's a good point we were talking
about how operators like you guys you
tip of the spear guys almost always to a
like almost always to a man have girls
you when you have children yeah it's
always girls when they have children
always girls do you know that high
testosterone too like most uh ufc
fighters don't have girls really joe
rogan
um
sweats to that brian stan has like nine
girls jon jones has like 17 girls god
it's all girls
and i have two boys
[ __ ]
listen we're not saying you're not tip
of the spear nor are we saying you're
like maybe in comedy i mean comedy you
know champion level physique yeah
you're gonna make a lot of videos but
yeah i feel like i have a lot of
testosterone i have two boys yeah first
special forces command uh they they have
like did research trying to figure out
you suck trying to figure out what is
going on if you walk into a special
forces oda and you and you take all 12
dudes and you say all right
carlos how many kids you have he's like
four girls ben how many kids do you have
three girls like you just go right down
the row if you find a boy in the mix
he is like he's held up as like this
adonis
up in the air i wonder if that's
nature's way of saying there's too much
testosterone here we gotta we gotta
balance [ __ ] out
yeah surround it all the time you know
pheromones are pumping testosterone i
don't know what it is that is strange
it's weird they have a bunch of but you
have boys
i mean i i had to get weird to get a boy
yeah you were saying you have a
technique would you i don't i don't have
i don't own the technique i did research
to find out that there are there's a
there was a plethora of techniques like
positions yeah position so male swimmers
swim faster but don't last as long so
like an ovulation if you have
if if you if you come
early in our ovulation like there's more
time for the female swimmers to make it
up there but if you have
to make it to egg to fertilize but if
you do at the end of the ovulation it's
just gonna be the fast boys and then
it's over and if you didn't get a a boy
cool you could try next time um
positions
like trying to deposit deeper and then
um it is so gender is a hundred percent
determined by the male 100
and body fat body temperature uh like
athleticism these are all things that
skew towards
female offspring whoa yeah so by so if
you you just finished working out for
example bad time bad time bad time do
you want you want to be on bed rest yeah
a man like you was going to be on bed
right reading
watching hallmark i took a month off
i flew to germany
i hung out in like with a bunch of
german and nordic norwegian
like dudes that look like this dude like
all of them look like that guy but why
would you do that just because it lowers
your testosterone
cold cold weather no hot showers no
briefs no exercise you were dead serious
about you did all this just for the boy
for the boy no exercise no exercise holy
[ __ ] yeah
i mean i did like some dancing uh yeah
like beer gardens in germany you know
yeah like a good logan you know and like
yeah i'm not gonna say no
yoga in the morning they got like those
little uh the outfits that the the girls
wear yeah yeah did you go did you change
your diet
oh yeah you did yeah so what's that for
the boys charcuterie boards
wine
i mean how probably how you live
how you live is what i did to try to get
this brian counts yeah and then like
it's soft
positionally i sit down the sword for a
month to try to try to get a boy and
then like afterwards i'm holding my
naked wife by the ankles like shaking
her you're like come on get in there see
[ __ ] i'm not joking and then it worked
oh yeah i got a boy got me a boy that's
just the one
check three girls and a boy he's the
hope
how old is he now yeah he's seven does
he have your athletics he's a savage he
is yeah how can you not be the one he
looks
the opening scene in the last mohicans
we're talking about lacrosse yeah um he
plays a cross he's got striations on his
shoulders he's got this v on his back
already already he has long hair that
goes down to the middle of his back and
he takes off his lacrosse helmet and
it's like matted and tangled
from being all sweaty and uh he just
looks like a savage that's straight out
of the last time he gets and he plays
hockey he writes motivations you want to
say it out loud but like when my son
gets out of the pool he's with his
buddies i see my son kind of like
shredded me i'm like [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
i do i do say it out loud i look at like
the fat dude to the fat dad bods and i
look at their their kids that are lame
i'm like
you guys know what's up you know yeah
you know look at look at my boy yeah
yeah